[Music]
so
yes welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome
rice and evil we're back baby
feels good
so here we are where our shitty rusty
knife
possibly last episode i'm thinking
probably two more but i put
last episode just to get more people in
here how are you doing all the people
that swarmed okay
so i read your comments and apparently i
can get the shotgun
no sorry magnum if i go back
to the swan which one was that
it's this one yeah so i guess we
go back here i'll try that
and while i'm on my way there if i'm
walking the wrong way just tell me
because i'm not sure at all i try i try
to understand but
comments are never specific they just go
you can get it
that's cool
i remember when uh having fabrics like
that in video games was like whoa
that's so cool now it's like standard
[ __ ]
well that's definitely blocked off but
we're not going there anyway
getting the magnum we're getting
everything baby we can definitely
loud hello i assume this is locked
no okay nice uh
there's a labyrinth puzzle here
it's a crank here
wait where does this go exactly have we
explored this
broken i'm not sure we've been here
well we definitely haven't been here
sorry box i had to do it too oh [ __ ]
we're going to snipe some [ __ ]
bricks gopro
i hear one way closer
hey you are my stinker rooney
all right bro just land
i ain't got time
apparently you don't even have to
headshot them
it's like what's the point
i hear another one land beat
land please
not there can't shoot you there it's
definitely something to breathe
all right midair let's get it
[Applause]
here comes nailed it
midairshot let's go ready to go pro
don't think i don't hear you
[Applause]
don't think for a second i don't yeah
that's a big pile of
cows someone was here before me huh
hello i
uh oh yeah you were oh you scared me
oh god don't kill me push him
push him push them away didn't i
ah don't make me waste ammo thank you
crystal skull for that little fella
thank you
it's still red is there something else
in there
it's the flying one you want to come
inside you come inside
i invite you please come inside join us
come inside please
i'm right what the here
is he doing
fine don't come inside [ __ ]
oh these guys are rich they're
definitely worth checking out hello
damn it i can make so many chor ba de
lunga from this this is [ __ ]
there all right here another one
in the dark oh there you are look at
this [ __ ] rooney he's like ah
i'm gonna fake sleep just like that
other guy
but none of my watch you fake sleeper
i've been tricked there's another one as
well
double fake sleeper go back to sleep
shot him in his armpit
he's already dead [ __ ]
you can't hit me because armpit shot
[ __ ]
yeah give me that any other fake
sleepers want to fake sleep
very rich all right we got more people
coming up
all up didn't the guy on the roof drop
something
hold up that's still red hold up
hello hello
yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't think about
that
there you are sniper ammo thank you
okay
uh blue i like that i like that more
blue please
all right where is this last guy up in
here
it's a it's going to be a big guy isn't
it
let's prepare for the worst let's
prepare
our pancakes
i come for the magnum let's peep on him
what's the situation in there
hello hey hey do you want to pancakes
i can't even peep on him this is so lame
hey buddy what a big oh it's a big guy
he hasn't spotted me yet how should we
kill him
okay watch this this is going to be pro
knife in the ass
that's how pros do it ass knight
what what
he should be dead buying now all right
fine you know what i'm leaving
i don't care
he's too fat he's too fat to fit through
here
that's his own problem
ah he's not too fat
that's crazy i hear another one
hello
i'm sure it's fine here we go is this
the magnum
yes wolf's bane it's beautiful i love it
look at this okay
mother miranda gave me a mountain now i
can do lots and lots of caddo
experiments so some romanians said
kadoment
what do you mean romaine is in the chat
help us out this is my secret special
laboratory
like corpse or something i did three
caddo experiments today but they all
went
pop and made a mess i put in the cado
and then i tried putting wolf blood from
a needle in to the spine okay
the person wriggled a lot and then
killed my assistant
rude oh like cadaver
got it okay the person wiggle okay yeah
i could not hold it down so i put it in
a cage
now i have to feed it
hate that all right let's find this
little cadillac
it sounds like a pal you know hey that's
my cadeau over there my best bud you
know
all right let's try this bad boy out on
this guy clearly hiding outside our
window
hey miss kadau
is that a big it's a silver inside
morphe
shoot him in the ass oh
that's gonna hurt caddo
oh so the magnum it whoa the magnum is
so good you're so bad
you're so bad okay
so that thing goes to wolfie scotty
got it uh-huh okay
uh-huh
hey depends on context what context do
you think it is
zombies and vampires and
werewolves you tell me uh what is this
what is that let's check that out
yes up here
the one shot in the ass is really uh
doing a lot huh
a little shortcut
why excuse me why
okay sure we did a thing i guess
all right we got the magnum that's what
we wanted and we got it
very good i think that means we can
proceed to oh wait
i didn't see this
no clearly i did what the [ __ ] no i
didn't
oh mermaid so we can do the mermaid
puzzle which is is that the one
labyrinth uh i assume that's a mermaid
because it's water
yeah let's do it
i almost missed it geez
oh my god can the wind shell out
uh what's inside where's the entrance it
doesn't say
all right we're going in the windmill
this is how you walk
what's it this way mermaid puzzle
mermaid puzzle
which floor and where does it say the
floor first floor
this is not first floor
all up
hold up sony
oh it's it's not in this building
i thought it was next here we go
that saved me a lot of time thank you
small brain
mermaid ball whoa look at him go
you go ball all right we haven't
actually failed at these yet but i have
a feeling they get more difficult right
you go ball you go ball
all right i don't see how you could fail
this so let's
keep going down the hall yes
you can fail here but we're not gonna
excuse me roll ball
uh what the [ __ ] is happening am i
supposed to know what's going on here
ah there we go
what the [ __ ] i can't see resident
there we go
okay cue
very cute what do we get oh
jacksepticeye skull super rare
wow epic
so we're not going to the laboratory
we're going to
okay we got all this stuff nice
time to progress then
um i don't know how many other weapons
you get in the game
we're going back to the altar
but i want to upgrade the magnum maybe
i don't know
thank god for gpu and their code
pewdiepie very good
i'm in that after workout after lunch
dip right now i'm just like ah
feels good as you wish
thank you crystal skull you can have it
crystal wing you can have it crystal
beast sheesh
and t coin
elliot let's sell the coin [ __ ] it
what are they gonna do now to spend like
kings
all right power give me power yeah rate
of fire
yeah one moment please maxed out already
[ __ ]
oh this is the sound that all sorts of
weapons equipment
will do them for a small fee no he
doesn't
i guess we wait what is this oh
flashbangs
uh-huh okay
okay john girl
we used to be alive
and we're missing fish we have the
finest fish
that's something till next we meet
kind of want to shoot his belly is that
weird oh they don't let you
they don't let you shoot his belly
[ __ ] [ __ ] this game
um i care about organize my inventory
right now
[Music]
is this the last area no where is the
last area
it's this guy we go here i assume
yeah yeah
yeah i saw a video of someone throwing a
dynamite on him and he basically just
goes
and that's it he's a tank i'll give him
that
but i'm not wasting a dynamite just for
that oh i wonder which way we should go
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
why should we still get lost
let's go good luck
thanks game you're the best so we have
creepy staircase or
possibly loot in the bushes you know
what we do
this is what we do on this channel [ __ ]
i went the right way
i wanted to go the wrong way
creepy stairs it is hell yeah what's up
creepy
oh that's a really creepy excuse me
[Applause]
are they alive cringe
supposed to be dead
who's making all this noise who's doing
all the ruckus here
ah is it too passed to the same way
no it isn't this is different why is
this different
we shall explore
uh ah [ __ ] there's a lot of that's a
you're so slow you're too slow
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
all right don't move fake orakais
is addy no spotted yet
noise is zaddy
you know you're at the end because
they're throwing way more enemies i.e
thank you cool
don't mind if i do
um are these the werewolf form
shouldn't i bind my magnum then
oops that's not what i wanted to do my
bad
maybe i'll bind it instead of this yeah
herbs
give me your loot
is that a big boy no it's normal
back off back off me
yes they always make a sound when they
die and i'm like oh did i not kill it oh
it's dead
why does it sound like there's like 500
of them
hello look i can do that too bro
are they behind me where
uh oh [ __ ] hold up
let me just reload and i'll be right
there okay
sounds like they're all around me oh
they're here
oh come on dude
nice so you're supposed to use sniper
here
uh where are they
where but where
it sound like they're in mountains
where are they
are they just trying to throw me off
i hear so many of them
okay explosive rounds we haven't tried
those yet
how do i use those
uh is that for the grenade launcher yeah
it is
isn't it i don't know
okay we can blow this place up
that's cool but why
surely we're gonna get ambushed then
yeah a big fight coming up
they're telling me kado means present
now
okay
i'll take it
hey ladies y'all got hey
hey that's my move
[ __ ] finishing them up
oh [ __ ]
stop stop strafing [ __ ]
let me loot them really quick i don't
want to run back
we can shoot first ow you did you okay
fine you win you win
you're better don't point at me
i hit his [ __ ] throat hold up i
didn't see the
nothing
give me give me luke give me give me
love give me give me lit
there you are
there's one more here no
okay no loot
[Music]
oh more explosions
dude this looks so [ __ ] what happened
here
hello that ain't nice you can't sell me
that
ice i'm swedish ice is free okay
wait where was the there it is okay
the lever zombies come bing bang bong
you know
ah [ __ ]
all right everyone chill all right fine
hey how you doing
oh [ __ ] how do you get up here
are we how we hurt thee
oh come on he ducked all right now
you're pissing me
thank you
fine
i hit their [ __ ] necks dude it's like
valerie
i'm not wasting two snipers
stop [ __ ] strafing
[ __ ] the controls are so awful when
you're up close
nice not too bad
not good not terrible i would say
summarize my gameplay
actually it's all terrible
so got plenty
give me oh 25 jesus
generous out here
give me
oh okay i thought i only carried one for
some reason thanks guys
wish i could loot the guys oh wait maybe
i can
maybe it's not a good idea to snipe them
if i can't get their loot but maybe then
they made it so that they don't drop
loot no they definitely do i see it
sad
yeah heisenberg is next
okay so how do i get
i can't
[Music]
can i wait for zombies i don't think
there's any more so many crows
they're angry because i didn't call for
backup from episode one i know it
i'm sorry there's no romanian police
i thought we were going to like the
industrial park
thank you thank you
yes
what how do you miss a box
yes we go here
sniper time
i don't see any
as it's called in romanian
damn so many explosion things here nice
okay what we're gonna
do we're good we're gonna put pancake
right here
[Applause]
and then we got
oh [ __ ]
i can't shoot it now
are they attacking me from behind oh
[ __ ] what do we do now
we're gonna have to plow through here
oh don't dodge my shotgun
[Applause]
yeah yeah yeah i
want some i can go here
owie
i don't know what i'm doing am i
supposed to run here
all right oh my god you stop strafing
okay big guy oh big guy
ten twelve ah come on
let me reload one two three
all right hey you made me hit the big
guy
oh my [ __ ] god i was so far away
thank you they're behind me apparently
thank you
give me the low give me the loot
i'm going bye
this guy suck [ __ ] you
my hands are fine they're made of steel
irons and ir ethan
that was a run part wasn't it
i would say nail it but i don't think it
is i don't know we made it out of life
at least
hey give me more
goat give me wisdom
and strength thank you
i left a lot of loot just saying
i don't know i felt like that was a part
you're supposed to run through and i
grabbed whatever i could
well what are these are they making love
oh that's so sweet and maybe i shouldn't
kill them after all
if we
oh yeah so calm
but as soon as we this is such a
fighting area isn't it
okay let's scout out before we jump down
yes there's healing there a crate there
possibly they jump from there there i
will go
lay a pancake as soon as i go down 360
pancake
i can't be bothered
pancake now that's not good
it's fine honest i should reload my
shotgun actually
he's so big and sexy hello
he can block
i was behind all right you know what i'm
going on the pancake [ __ ] you
[Music]
all this trick in there book oh what is
he doing hey don't throw that at me
ah i said not to get go on the pancake
now
no no i shoot them in the leg
what the pancake does nothing it does
nothing panic
i'm in panic mode now the pancakes does
absolutely nothing on this man
it's we got a magnum this dude it looks
like a werewolf
don't oh thank god i was saved by him
yeah magnum [ __ ] [ __ ]
magnum [ __ ] magnum
oh hold up let me reload let me relay
where you going where are you going
where are you gonna do a pair huh
in the head
you're so weak oh you're so bad
you're bad at gate don't jump jump
i'm out of ammo [ __ ] uh okay sniper
sniper
weak santa claus is dead kids i
killed senna i take full responsibility
what are you gonna do man
yeah [ __ ] you santa
magnum
hell oh they gave us all the stuff to
use and i
only used a pancake
rich
what else you got now load it off
see little but there's more things
this crate nice
oh this looks pretty wow
time for a g fuel set
zero that pewdiepie zero dash
santa one death cringe oh look at that
there's two of them
no wait these are not crystals are they
do you think these are crystals
oh we're gonna be rich today
oh we're gonna be super duper rich oh my
god so many crystals
i saw like 50 of them
wait hold up
what is that a crystal
no a crystal
real crystal
it's raining money i should go back here
after i
beat the game to get rich and live a
happy life
hold up am i missing any it's like
sparkling everywhere it's kind of
like no
at
see a [ __ ]
they're not worth that much but i'll
take it
okay scanning
i don't see any else do you
scanning
no nah
can i check the map here oh it's blue
okay
that makes it easier
i thought it was only houses for some
reason that were red or blue
okay before we deal with that we looped
oh the last one woohoo
uh-huh what same
you're the real deal ethan well done
quit hiding cheese today i'm not letting
you get out of this
cool your jets just a little bit more
and you're all wrapped up i'll lend you
a hand
so in exchange in exchange what
first of all come to me put all the
flasks in the altar
and i'm sure you'll figure the rest out
well i have so far
all by myself chad barely told me
anything
god damn it if anything chant just tells
me uh the wrong side
what kind of name is that goggle here
hey what's up my name is guglielmo
you got a problem i don't think so my
name is
get in the boat ethan hold up
yep we got everything what is that what
is that
cannibal plunder we should get that on
the way out
a little uh road trip snack
oh
oh ho ho ho
how far was it a little bit further
[Music]
all right
nice how you doing baron
it's all blue here she
what's down there then
must investigate perhaps a lever to open
the gate
so we can get the cool thing
is it blue here it is not breaking
what do we got here then what's all this
then caddo
present implementation note subjects
whatever me my
is that a reference from romania
the national anthem of romania
affinity kiddo failed to grow body
transformation drop in commission
another lichen i know lichen is a
werewolf okay sent to pasture
21 female no occupation no history of
illness but she did
noble descendant not from the village
blood disease result very high affinity
no loss of cognition
arbitrarily able to control body
transformation
applied cognition control procedure sent
for observation
no
i don't think that was a reference by
the way just for the record
but hey who knows
is it blue yet nope all right
i want more magnum shots
let me squeeze past the caddos
hey i'm busy i'm busy oh i shot the
wrong one but still headshot
don't come near me i
don't stray don't straight stop strafing
stop
don't stop strafing
that was a headshot how are you not dead
come on hold up let me reload let me
reload let me
reload told him bro
i told you bro yay
okay let me get that phantom
phantom fish phantom fish fish we're
gonna get the fish
holy [ __ ] bros where's the phantom fish
phantom fish so glorious it's by the
harbor
hmm i think i know where this
is phantom fish will be mine
phantom fish i will fish you
another uh no we have that one
is it blue yet okay
we're going fishing boys all ye
all right it did say it was blue
but is there a way to open this canal
wait a minute we want to go there
hold up
where the [ __ ] do these guys come from
honestly
i killed the rare fish already but
ah that pisses me off
[Applause]
well clearly you can't go there there
must be a road here
right yeah we probably we will probably
connect to it now maybe
who knows i don't know
i'm so excited for fishing damn it
[ __ ] this game yes
one misfortune leads to glory you're
dead
you're not a fish but i'll take it come
on come on stop moving you're making the
pain worse
why are you so hard to kill stop it
you increase the pain by fighting away
i saw one more you're a little
chicken here little chicken
sorry i got a little excited
okay what do we got
this poultry here uh-huh
can we enter one of these
found you go by goal
this one has fresh flowers on it is that
something does that mean anything
don't think so okay
well so does this one so whatever
uh finally we can sorry which lock was
this
oh we could have gone here earlier
right
she you know what this means
bros
excuse me
excuse me who dare interrupts my singing
who made that noise hello
demon what the [ __ ] was that
a lull demon steaming
all right we have one this is a point
merchant
and then yeah
cannibals plunder let's go there
it's the last thing we don't have i
don't know if we can go there but hey
it's worth a shot right
is it this way yeah
i gotta make sure
there's a crystal in the church okay
remind me later because uh
oh right because we we went right okay
so it's this way
cool a little bonus area maybe fish
fish fish fish
come on come on fish come on fish
come on fish
come on fish come on fish
don't do me like this fish don't do me
like this fish come on
no fish what's all this thing
oh [ __ ] you i want a fish
get out of here
fish
oh we got a goat coming up
not a fish but maybe it can transform
like a pokemon
when they evolve i don't know
oh you're not a goat uh for [ __ ] sake
uh all right i'm just gonna shoot it
because
oh he's not dead oh suffer
suffer little pig
sorry about that bro don't fight back
don't it's just cringe
don't fight back don't fight back don't
fight back don't stop it
you extend your pain
remember when i felt bad about killing
them me neither all right i saw crystal
or something on the ground
i don't know how it dropped but there it
is thank you
i accept your meat this sounds
unpleasant
well that's loud again
no oh
hello oh that's a big boy
time to get out i have so much stuff
it's the grenade launcher yeah boom
completely unfazed are you serious
all right
okay
[ __ ]
i actually heard a little bit
um
don't do this bro don't do it bro don't
do it bro
don't do it bro don't do this
don't do this don't do this bro
don't do it don't do it bro
don't do it bro don't do it bro
all right i don't want to waste more
ammo
you're gonna miss ah double strike
triple ah ah we are we are we i'm sorry
after free fall
don't ever frickle me again i was trying
to be nice to you and now
you pissed off the wrong sweet [ __ ]
okay all right don't do the triple don't
do the friction
you know i'm going upstairs [ __ ] you i'm
going upstairs you can't
you can't join oh there's a thing nice
yeah don't follow me yeah don't fool me
what it does nothing nothing
[ __ ] bro stop
bro stop
you can't hit how many [ __ ] stuff
just die bro die
stop just die bro bro
stop why you're not dead i killed you so
many
[ __ ] [ __ ] go where'd it go
yeah you're dead now
what the [ __ ] birds ah don't do the jump
attack
don't do the jumping jacks i just want
to know
what are the things stop
stop stop shame
yeah all right surely he's got one shot
left
surely surely you can't come up here
you can't come up here but he can climb
he was one shot left i knew it yeah
control that well that was nice
and clean and easy wouldn't you say what
do you have there
nice thank you
thanks
for an [ __ ] oh thanks
i need to recoup after that [ __ ]
they're so big and strong and sexy
okay all right let's pick up all the
missing loot
i felt like i saw something maybe that
was it and
it's definitely more
oh don't mind if i do
come on there's got to be more
i didn't check over here
oh 20 why thank you
hm
[Music]
could i have shot that down on top of
him or something yeah
can't go in here it's blue okay
uh we'll go here then
oh my god why do you have to put so many
this better be fish please be fish i
need more fish not me
oh my god fish fish have you heard of
fish
oh my god dude where's the [ __ ] fish
in this game
i need fish nothing else nothing else
stop oh i'm so mad
where's the fish there better be fish
fish fish fish
more fish please more please
fish ah fish that fish
eh oh my god
more fish please that's not enough
that's not enough
not nearly not never enough fish all
right give me this
oh so sweet
fish there's a fish in here
well it's a fish in here maybe there's
fish in the
bag no
okay i don't know if i looted everywhere
here
oh i definitely didn't kill everything
that's a lot of you
[Applause]
all right fine
oh no
yeah you're dead how does that feel bad
i bet
or maybe good oh there's dynamite i
forgot to use
[ __ ] ah damn it
did we check all of this uh i think we
did
yeah we got to go what's all this thing
that's the back entrance is there
something behind the house
without it nope all right
keep moving out
let's go we're getting there good
progress today
good luck thanks uh
oh we haven't we missed something in the
church you guys told me
i mean is it really worth doing the rest
before we
like i don't i'll do the church for sure
i don't think i care about every single
house or like two handgun ammo or some
[ __ ]
so there was something in here
that i missed we checked the computer
already where
oh crystal
ends blue you know what
sage
i missed you girl think about you every
single day
you were the best part of the game so
far
i wish there was the whole game around
you really
anyway
one two three
all loot belongs to me
what do you guys reckon there's no big
treasures left we got all the big
treasures
the real question is can i get more fish
in the game
you know what i'm saying
that's what this is really all about
saving my child i don't know i there's
fish to find
all right we have a [ __ ] ton of stuff my
greatest pleasure to see you return
alive
thank you as you wish
six so rich
oh yellow wow 11.
bro
yes oh 200k
[ __ ] damn
all right [ __ ] i need more fish
i need six fish please do take a look at
my new stock
wait a good deal if i say so myself
you got more i'm even
man you got [ __ ] off what are you
talking about
[Music]
to hunger it used to be alive
oh my god what are we going to do with
this 200 000
i could buy magnum bullets that's right
welcome they are really useful
uh can i buy so oh sorry pay me
no mind a sniper
shotgun handgun i can't buy magnum
that would have been good though please
come again
okay we're on a quest for fish now
nothing else
right is it weird that i want to see him
naked
i just want to see how big those man
titties are you know
that uh that's weird okay i didn't say
anything
hold up we should not place the last
flask before we know
before we confirm that we have all the
fish we need head okay we got a donation
from calmer olsen definitely head to
louise's house if you see this it's on
the map
you'll be in for a nice surprise uh okay
sorry who's louisa again is that the
girl we saved in the beginning yeah it
is
okay we can go
a little sus but
i'll go mr calmer
where was louise's house again it was up
here wasn't it
[ __ ] the map you know that's for idiots
[ __ ] i need a man um
yeah it's through here
oh i remember this stupid house you have
to go through
it makes no [ __ ] sense this stupid
map can suck my ass
oh god i'm lost again i hate the map so
much
i did it
wait you can go by the chairs of a
[ __ ] sake
all right it's not this way at all oh my
[ __ ] god
that's fine
i hate i hate the navigation it's so
irritating
i think i have a decent sense of
location but man this game just [ __ ] me
up
yeah i have the rocket launcher we have
all the weapons as far as i know
oh oh is it what the [ __ ] is that
excuse me oh god i don't have magnum
shots
hold up
pancake one
pancake two
and sniper rooney
where is he
i wanted to turn around
is jack in the chat what up boy
watch this clutch gamer moment jack
perfect headshot
he's going to get oh that's fast that's
a lot that's a lot
faster pancake there's nothing walk in
the pancake
ah he's not walking on the pancake jack
look away no
it's fine it's fine pancakes
i just gotta craft a little
something and then walk on the mine
where the [ __ ] are they hold up
it's fine
i'm i'm done there we go there's a
pancake
uh yeah he can't climb over fences so
we're good
and he can't sheets us
[ __ ] this guy
i really wish i saved that
all right we're gonna have to pancake
again
there you go present don't follow me oh
god please
all right there was one more pancake i
had here somewhere all right
where is he there is don't walk on it
it's so dumb
[ __ ] does he ever die
[ __ ]
[ __ ] out okay all right more pecking
place it he missed me
[ __ ] he doesn't mind
that's fine
[Applause]
see my strafe there right before he came
he's almost there
nice sheesh
[Music]
i was just surprised you're right
but why
can we not enter the house again
did it burn down or something what
happened here
joking
we're running kind of low on a lot of
stuff now because we're fighting all
this [ __ ]
wow wow
what an [ __ ] was that the girl's
father
prehistoric looking creature i doubt it
check the necklace which necklace
can i sell it oh there it is
nanny
why
uh
examine the necklace again
oh my god thanks bros
let's go look we
entered the house now which wait hold up
where does that key go though
i know it's not here but
this is all burned down
oh right she lived over
somewhere else our house was actually
no that's
sorry where is this near ceremony side
tunnel where where i don't or ceremony
side again
uh i don't remember
ceremony site
oh golly it doesn't show
if i zoom out
red building to the left this one is it
that one
no that's unlocked they can't be that
one their ceremony site
okay let's start heading over there then
we're maxing out this playthrough
i like it
[Music]
is there fish there
there is a door there oh my [ __ ] god
are you serious
why are you telling me about other sides
then well i'm right there and then you
get angry at me
shut the [ __ ] up how about that i mean
thanks for helping me i appreciate it
god damn you [ __ ] trolls
i need the enigma code to
understand what the [ __ ] you guys are
saying nine times out of ten all right
where's the
you're joking with me you can't enter at
all what the [ __ ] are you smoking
oh eat ass eat ass all of you
i hope you got rashes in your armpits
and
elbows
okay
i hope you all get warts on your butt
and i hope you all get knows
okay i'm joshing
in before i have to go back again
okay okay okay guys chat one thing at a
time okay
let's just do one thing at a time here
you can't keep walking back and forth
tell me different things
let's start off with the [ __ ]
ceremony side thing right said under the
bridge
okay
let's try that let's try that first
doesn't look like i can get there
i'll look at all the fish guys
under the bridge of the cats
okay from here which direction
north is that way actually listen
okay north is this way
which bridge are you talking about this
one this one this one
[Music]
a bridge god it's so hard to decipher
there's some people trolling now as well
uh
okay i'm getting a snack you guys figure
it out
good luck
uh
oh
[Music]
all right have we reached the conclusion
of which [ __ ] way to go
okay as a donation i'll trust that
bridge at castle excellent donation
number three the lone road
two hallways one of them has a chest
okay
let's start with that
i already go here oh thank you
chocolate who you're a real one
thank you nice
it's not a fish but
i'll take it
what's in here then zombies
okay
already lowered the bridge [ __ ]
why is there an exclamation point there
i already took the bug
big fans giving me advice skedaddle
hmm what do we put here then this is for
later maybe
hold up we lost lucia's
key so that's the only place you can use
it huh
you already got all the fishes you can
get there's no more fish left
and anto you break my heart
ah fine i guess we're done
ah my soul it burns
okay i think we should suck up a little
bit then
do a save and then uh we'll put the last
jar
shall i choose something for you
food is life i know and i can't get fish
whoa eighty thousand
oh twenty pounds no
we have so much meat that we can't do
anything with and it breaks my
heart you will part with this three
hundred thousand i'm more than happy to
purchase it
oh he only sells one what a cheap ass
thank you for your purchase
we're still rich as [ __ ] god damn
pay me no mind till next we meet all
right well
you stay rich by not spending money so
that's all i'm spending
there's a machine gun okay
oh my god i don't have space for a
machine gun
we could sell this actually hair trigger
oh good i was just thinking of ways to
pass the time
this is all an investment even
where is it
little and often fills the purse as they
say
a good deal if i say so myself
now i already got the boat fish
y'all need to stop talking if you don't
know
there's an ak-47 in this game i know it
okay so i assume that goes on the
ceremony side
think come on
oh
what's going on i don't know what's
going on over here
wow what's happening
there you go there it is
oh so fit well
now that's a bridge oh
and i'm going down bye
i didn't want to walk the bridge anyway
damn we have so much time with you
oh this is nauseating no [ __ ] nauseating
no [ __ ] thing not gating this is
knocking
there we go
don't worry about the kid even it'll be
fine
oh we are going to the industrial park
uh
[Music]
but i suppose you survive worse back in
america
i like you thank you i'd like to speak
to you about rose
america yo there's a tank in the game
don't worry it's not a trap
it's that what are you planning
uh if you remember in the seventh one
there was the brother right and he had
this whole
place with a [ __ ] ton of traps so
i assume we gotta watch watch our feet
here
okay okay
lot
need to die
eisenberg breaking bad reference meme
he's romanian you know
why is it so common here
what is he cooking we can't see it
oh we can't
what the hell what the freak mia
truth hurts stay away heisenberg
let me guess you're thinking take me out
like the others and then he gets to go
and save rose right
yeah that's stiff generally my daughter
look you got this all wrong
shut the [ __ ] hole
what are you talking about you think
this is a game
uh i said [ __ ]
lady supersize [ __ ]
okay
don't you get it no it's a test
to see if you're strong enough to be a
part of miranda's film i don't want to
be a part of miranda's family neither
did i but here
we are and i'm next in line right
kill me move up the chain well [ __ ] that
i don't give a damn about your personal
issues
i just want to fix my daughter so do
i do you have any idea how powerful a
kid is
even miranda scared her
last time you freak i swear to god
what the [ __ ] are they doing down there
you and me then together we go
save rogues and we can use her to grind
miranda into beasts
i like my daughter is not a weapon [ __ ]
you
last chance you don't want to find out
what's in that hole
i'll take my chances no he seems cool
ah come on let me
pick the choice at least
all right what's in the hole what do we
got
oh god
propellerhead
this way yeah and then this way
and then not this way
then this way let's have a look at him
okay that's not today
no it ain't
that was clean nice
that was cool what was that thing what
what i don't
know propellerhead
rusted scrap here
jump up uh-huh
okay
looks like we're going down
but first we go up or should we
okay let's check down first wait am i
walking in circles again
nope
[ __ ] is going on here
why are they signifying for me to go
here i guess it's just to go back up
oh still ready
what's all these things
oh [ __ ] they got they got armor on their
[Applause]
head
[Music]
oh
so many head shots there did you see
that
forget this gun is automatic um
all right
it's blue thank god i don't want to go
back
there in vr
lady miranda's uh big kitty adventure
this place is messed up whoa that's so
cool gotta get upstairs
escape i love this place i want to be
homemade
is he whoa very half-life too
cool
nice is this a map hold up
oh what it's unexpected
uh-huh this place is messy
damn actually let's
chat with him first yes yes
there it is no
what is this shotgun semi-automatic
shotgun mixing
then we have this already what's all
this
okay explain to me what the [ __ ] is
going on
he's selling so much stuff now [ __ ]
sake
which one should i get this one or this
one
if this is a shotgun
this is a handgun
i could sell my old shotgun and get this
hundred thousands customizable increases
ammo capacity
i thought it was rich but look at this
this is 200 that's a lot more than 200
please let me know if you'd like to
strengthen your weapons
i'm thinking about it
it's confusing because like
i can't afford both obviously
uh
reduces recoil you could buy this and
the handgun one
sal the sniper are you mad
[Music]
you have three options sell things off
throw them away
or buy a bigger bag so we have to sell
stuff
do you have enough firepower i can now
offer an expanded weapon modification
service
all right i could do this
carry on
and it cleans up my inventory a little
bit
carry on do you have enough firepower
i can now offer an expanded weapon
modification service
i don't think i'll ever use this
i'm too scared to do it
how much does my handgun go for
600 no 75 000 oh [ __ ] and the shotgun
goes for
a lot as well
let's sell the old ones that gives us
17 000. we should afford it both then
am i hate that i've done this
but i want it
oh my it won't fit in your bag
all right gotta organize i guess uh
boom
all the supplies at the top i guess
oh my god we still have so much [ __ ]
meat why do we have so much meat
that's more like it
oh actually maybe this was integrated
there but whatever
[Laughter]
no
[Music]
does this fit my my gun though
the v61 yeah
[Laughter]
cool and then red dot sight for what
shotgun
we could even afford
increased rate of fire
it's for the sig this is for the other
one
an interesting selection
[Music]
till next we meet
okay new gun
cool two new guns
since we don't have any shotgun ammo
maybe i should
i don't know
pancake bind for now oh right we can
upgrade as well oh my god
ah if only you had the funds indeed
65 000 [ __ ]
oh broken all sorts of weapons
modifications and we'll do them for a
small fee
ah
sell the wolf spain
should we sell the wolf man
i mean we have [ __ ] a lambo for it
apologies but i don't extend credit
you [ __ ]
there's more magnum ammo let's start
with this and we'll know what to do
later
cool let's jump up
how does the shotgun oh where's my red
dot though
i guess there is a red dot
hello how are you
okay the brother gave us a lot of money
now either way i'm gonna be pissed you
don't want us
looks like some sort of lock mechanism
looks easy to break
well
i broke it hello
hey be nice
stop wiggling your [ __ ] head
oh nice they drop a lot of stuff now
okay cool
nice feel like a badass now
red room oh
[Music]
let's be careful
feels like we're nearing the end at
least maybe not fully but
sooner rooney in my spoon a pony
first we gotta kill a lot of these guys
ah come on
wiggle head gang
[Music]
miss me [ __ ]
yeah give me that money more skulls
please
more money please more everything please
took me what 10 hours to realize i don't
have to pull out my weapon to do that
this came as a reflex i kept doing it um
okay there's definitely more enemies
or where will they come from
i don't think i have anything to put
there
hmm
so we make the mold for that and the
iron
what's all this thing
still red but we're coming back here
why is it going away from me
[ __ ] it's so hard
to aim
[Applause]
trying my damnest
[ __ ] it's the beer guys
oh [ __ ] he's alive what the [ __ ]
i thought i killed him
gotta confirm the kill i guess jesus
what the [ __ ] is that what was that
a cable in my face get out of here
skidaddle
this with the power style
ah oh [ __ ] propeller man
we have yet to face propeller man
you're alive aren't you
all right fine be dead
did he just can i get that
oh what is this i thought it was
something fun
oh sure sure
fine i was leaving anyway nerd
he can't open doors he's got a drill for
a hand
[ __ ]
he's blocking dude
that's not good
don't do this we can be friends
don't block come on come on i can do
this all day
baby all day [ __ ]
um
whoa whoa
oh
somewhere here i don't know where let's
do the mold thing first
bing
ah oh can i touch it can i drink it
forbidden juice i want it
seems useful
seems useful he says [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay what the [ __ ] did i miss though
this story's a lot kind of sus
i don't know i think i'm good
we're gonna come back here again anyway
hey hey
don't don't camp the corners we talked
about this
don't do this ah
yes you're dead drop me money
more money please
what the [ __ ] is that
oh finally i feel like we haven't used
this in forever
[Music]
cool oh this is dead end okay
horse key i don't think i have that
[ __ ]
all right time to make a horse key
are we gonna shoot those
perfect game thank you
surely we're shooting
oh my gosh are we
okay
i'm not sure why i'm doing this but it's
happening either way
come on
oh my gosh
i'll wait for them oh there's a lot of
them
oh collide on that [ __ ]
that's cool
get out of here
man doesn't realize he can walk around
[Music]
idiot
yes more money there's more zombies too
but more money
[Music]
thank god i need ammo
oh my gosh what i'm totally hitting it
am i crazy
what
[Applause]
maybe i have to do more from the side or
something
nice at the focus there
sheesh all right last fellas
more vr for you [ __ ]
i'm hitting his ears or something
there we go
why is this still going i thought i
was the point of that
oh
hey master shooter
10 out of 10 baby cheers to that game
it's red
[ __ ]
becoming sloppy now
oh this is sick are they going to come
alive which one of you
which one of you eyes are you
is you is you
i'm sure none of them are gonna come
alive i'll just turn my back towards
them what is this
okay
i didn't think that would work but it
was worth a shot
backup generator missing a cog
i have cogs i have a crank
[ __ ] you game don't like my cranks
use grenade all right i'll trust you
guys
i trust you guys and about it
oh thanks guys maybe
you're bros after all
found the crank
can i put it in please
wait what the [ __ ] did i i put the crank
again
wait what the [ __ ] did i just pick up
i didn't pay attention what did i just
pick up
that's a treasure oh
no oh huh
okay
and we can combine it with something
um it's us
we can go down here
uh
so much stuff on the things i'm like
what can i leave it can i let there we
go
i have a guy
is that the that wasn't mine
what the [ __ ]
oh there we go
that's a pancake
oh thanks i got sorry i gotta
sneeze
hey look who's here
we got a guest in the
wanna studio me in the finale of
resident evil eggy
huh you're sleeping on the sofa
did you have a good nap
so sleepy but i can chow i shouldn't
laugh
i meant blowing my nose i don't know why
i said sneeze anyway
mechanical soldiers hello
that's swedish fully grown male corpse
used removed hard and implanted
muscle stimulation via electric shock
was suspect successful brain dead so
no high cognitive ability only moves by
destructive
instinct then stops suldot
attached headgear to the cranium
electrodes confirmed stable brainwaves
experiment one
ligand fight was dismantled and eaten
within three minutes
issues with destructive and murderous
capabilities
that's an issue apparently replace lower
part of arm with drill
not enough outward for effective
movement need live bodies perhaps
you blind the kettle reactor in the
chest output greatly increased
experiment two looking fine
destroyed three lichens in one minute uh
oh
there's gonna be some strong guys good
results but issues with the reactor
durability may stop functioning if the
reactor is destroyed
this reminds me of uh invincible that
evil villain in the show
have you guys watched that
hey another mold okay a lot of
backtracking coming up
it's a good show it's on amazon prime
it's the
comic book i believe i finished it the
other day
and i enjoyed it it wasn't like whoa but
it had some
whoa moment
definitely worth a watch
oh we got a map at last
if you like comic books i would say it's
a must-watch
yeah there's a villain that turns some
there's people into machines
just like this honestly they have a red
glowing thing on there
oh we got a shortcut thanks game
and um super [ __ ] strong too
is it like the boys it's very gory
but not edgy i would say
just looking around you know see if i
missed something
i never really got into the boys uh we
watched season one it was good but
i feel like it's the kind of thing i
would like
i know there's a pewdiepie reference in
it oh
i don't know which season that is
[ __ ] how do i get back i jumped down
is there no ladder oh geez i didn't oh
there it is
no that's not a ladder
i'm walking in circles
me and marks are watching uh real
euro camping relaxed camp laid-back
camping
laid back camp that's what it's called
we're on season two it's really good
it's exactly what it says it is a bunch
of cute girls
camping and it's relaxed
very good why am i walking the circles i
need to figure out where to go
we walked here anyway
[ __ ]
he's still alive
i can block it but keep forgetting it's
so stupid like
i don't think this is a block but it is
so we picked up a what did we pick up a
cog mold
we have to go back and make the cog
first
i know i have a map but i honestly okay
nice now i know where we are
strangely satisfying i like it
[Music]
i think uh judicial was a little
overhyped for me it was not bad by any
means
i liked it but
um
backup generator let's go
here we go at last
ah [ __ ] what we what have we done
oh ethan such a disappointment
i thought we could join forces against
that [ __ ] honestly
i'm down if you're still down dude
damn we could craft a lot uh
holy [ __ ]
okay
all right do your thing do your thing
to be her children she locked us away in
the village
damn the blocking is delayed dude
i'm not like my siblings
i want nothing more than to be free of
that [ __ ]
they're siblings so i need power
how do i not pick up i need enough power
to destroy her
okie dokie these are the fruits of my
power
the struggles against
what a freak
i don't know i like him
keep sneezing oh god
okay well he went that way we go this
way then
heisenberg think ethan
nice i like that meme
he still hasn't seen me what an idiot
that looks fun
i think he'll see me now
i thought i could get a cheeky shot in
shoot damn it's so slow i went for the
shot i should
all right low in hell [ __ ]
ugh
so should i shoot that
oh okay a little late but
now we know i'm sure it'll appear again
they charge up again okay cool
what the [ __ ] get out of here you
dangling [ __ ]
sniper oh okay
they give me sniper ammo i respond
[ __ ] all right let's uh use the thing
then
i want to try it out
well [ __ ] that did nothing
oh gosh miss me [ __ ]
so did i apparently oh my gosh
i hope those are worth a ton
[ __ ] was that all about electricity was
[ __ ]
oh this is another way to go up okay
that's a pancake
whoa two in one baby
hell yeah
nice start using those
did i use it too early maybe oh golly
it's pancake time
jesus that was not supposed to happen
hold up
that word
it did something
[ __ ]
died he died with his vr headset that's
kind of cute
what's all this thing iggy is not
comfortable on my lap what can i do for
you
there we go
we're at the part of the game where it's
just not scary anymore
oh god
no one saw nothing no one heard or saw
nothing okay
pancake nice
all right what are we doing
don't think i have a cold i don't know
keep sneezing
wait [ __ ] am i doing
reject here and then it's here
okay
whoa double drill man
you can't block this
i definitely want
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm stuck
i think we'll give this guy a pancake
oh he's back i just saw it
please yes i need a shotgun
well we know this place is huge but damn
room after room
first we gotta check downstairs
obviously come on
nothing
a tissue box i could use that
wait drawer no
we're back here
what the [ __ ] no memory gang
guess we'll go
some health would be great some herbs
i'll take herbs
come on let me eat the herbs
okay more fight coming up for sure
okay i got presents for you mane
okay we want to get behind oh he almost
turned
did i actually miss
we're kind of behind him i'm missing
dave
yeah wasn't this game supposed to come
up here is this out over here
why is it yellow here
it just got lazy probably
did i just i actually just did that
[ __ ] me
now walking from this way i see what i
did
oh my gosh
we're getting there gamers
whoa
again i didn't expect him to come back
at all
i made it i'm alive thanks we're
definitely gonna fight him soon
hey i'm looting here
are we back here cool let's talk to the
man
is he up here
no i want to go to the guy
the guy is going to come up right hey
my man my man
welcome
oh money money money money money money
money money
five of them money money money
let's keep that
to think i would buy such things
yes definitely oh god so expensive
oh you're breaking my balls here we just
need seven thousand more
i've procured some new items for you mr
winters
did you really um
thank you for your patronage
i'm sorry
i'm sorry but that's the end
of the stream and i will see you
tomorrow
okay don't go anywhere stay right where
you are
don't leave i'll be back to finish this
bad boy off tomorrow
hey yeah
thanks for joining the stream guys
really fun hope you um uh
really appreciate all the support
everyone watching thank you for being
here
have a great day bye bye brofist
[Music]